I come before you because I need my authority reinstated.
This was a vampire attack.
Get her down below!
Whatever you hear, don't scream.
The citizens have complete faith in the Church's ability to keep them safe.
You will not shake that faith.
What good is that faith when it's a lie.
If you take any action to leave the city, you will be stripped from the order,...
...and excommunicated immediately.
The war is long over.
It's not over.
Not for me.
Is this the world that I fought for?
No, but it's the only world we have left.
One of your own has broken his sacred vow.
You will find him dead or alive.
They bred a new army.
You are too late priest, this is their turn now.
Is it true what they say about priests? They wield the hand of God?
You have no idea what's coming priest.